[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
ein super praktisches rezept wenn ihr
keine zeit habt aber ein richtig
leckeres dessert zaubern wollt ich zeige
euch heute die einfache zubereitung
eines leckeren kirsch trudelt und das
beste ist hierfür benötigen wir keine
sonderbaren zutaten sondern wirklich
zutaten jeder zu hause hat zum einen ein
blätterteig den habe ich aus dem
kühlregal außerdem sauerkirschen aus dem
glas doppel rahmen frischkäse und ein
wenig magerquark für die bindung noch
etwas speisestärke und zum süßen nehme
ich puderzucker und vanillezucker später
benötigen wir noch ein verfehltes eigelb
und ein paar mandelblättchen
[Musik]
nun bereiten wir zuallererst die füllung
vor und hierfür geben wir frischkäse und
magerquark in eine schüssel und rühren
dass kurz glatt
[Musik]
danach geben wir voller zucker und
vanillezucker mit hinzu und drehen das
gut unter
[Musik]
damit wir auch eine schöne schnittfeste
masse nach dem backen erhalten geben wir
jetzt noch die speisestärke mit hinzu
[Musik]
auch die speisestärke wie sie jetzt gut
untergerührt und weil das mit dem
schneebesen nicht ganz so gut
funktioniert nehmt ihr hier am besten
euren teigs aber die kirchen habe ich
abtropfen lassen und gebe sie jetzt mit
in die masse und das auch nur mit dem
teig schrauber unter rühren damit ihr
sie euch nicht kaputtmacht
[Musik]
und falls ihr euch jetzt fragt ob ihr
stadt der kirchen auch andere früchte
nehmen könnt ihr könnt jede erdenkliche
frucht nehmen ich stelle mir auch man da
reden supergut vor oder aprikosen oder
sogar äpfel dann habt ihr nämlich einen
leckeren apfelstrudel
[Musik]
somit ist die blitz füllung auch schon
fertig und es geht weiter auf dem
backblech mit unserem blätterteig
[Musik]
den lege ich mir auf meinen mit
backpapier ausgelegtes backblech breite
ihnen ganz kurz aus und lege ihn schön
glatt hin und dann geht auch schon
weiter
die leckere füllung wird jetzt mit ich
verteilt das heißt nicht ganz bis zum
rand oben und unten lassen wir ein wenig
platz und an den seiten lassen wir mehr
platz
[Musik]
mit dem löffel rücken wird das ganze
noch ein wenig verteilt und dann geht es
weiter mit der form
[Musik]
nehmt euch am besten ein stumpfes messer
ich habe hier ein marzipan messer
genommen ist geht aber auch ein
einfaches buttermesser und dann
schneidet ihr euch die seiten schräg
entlang
[Musik]
auf der gegenüber liegenden seite
schneiden wir dann genau nach dem
gleichen prinzip
[Musik]
oben und unten muss der blätterteig
nicht eingeschnitten werden denn die
seiten die klappen wir jetzt einfach
alle ein
[Musik]
nun klappt ihr einen strand auf den
anderen und dienten könnt ihr so wie
hier auch noch schön zusammen legen
damit sie später optisch auch gut
aussehen
am besten funktioniert das formen
übrigens wenn der blätterteig schön
durch gekühlt ist und richtig frisch aus
dem kühlschrank kommt ihr könnt
selbstverständlich auch tiefkühl
blätterteig verwenden
der muss allerdings vorher auftauen
sobald wir dann am ende angelangt sind
verstreichen wir unseren kirsch trudel
jetzt mit eigelb hier habe ich ein
eigelb verquirlt und gäbe dass mit einem
pinsel auf dem blätterteig das eigelb
sorgt nach dem backen für eine schöne
braune und glänzende oberfläche der auf
ihn verzichten möchte der kann das ganze
auch mit milch bestreichen dann wird das
ergebnis nicht ganz so wie in meinem
video zu guter letzt geben wir darüber
noch mandl blätter und den sorgen später
auch noch mal für eine richtig schön
krank und einen richtig tollen geschmack
der kia strodl wird jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad in
der unteren eindruck leiste gebacken für
22 bis 25 minuten nach dem backen seht
ihr dann so aus und ich lasse ihn
zunächst vollständig auskühlen damit ich
ihn mit puderzucker bestäuben kann
[Musik]
und so macht der care strodl doch schon
einen richtig guten eindruck auf der
kaffeetafel
obwohl der gar nicht so lange gedauert
hat aber das müssen eure gäste ja nicht
wissen deshalb lasst die mich einfach
schmecken zu einem leckeren milchkaffee
oder einem schönen warmen kakao
[Musik]
falls ihr euch fragt wie lange der
leckere care strudel nun haltbar ist ich
gebe euch zwar nicht mehr als einen tag
weil er wirklich super lecker ist aber
der schmeckt am nächsten tag auch noch
mindestens genauso gut
[Musik]
hier seht ihr auch noch mal im anschnitt
wie schön fest unsere creme ist und dass
euch dann nicht auslaufen kann am besten
passt dazu jetzt noch ein häufchen sahne
oder eine kugel vanilleeis
falls ihr das ganze jetzt nach machen
möchtet dann schauten in die infobox
dort habe ich für euch alle genauen
mengenangaben aufgeschrieben und dann
freue ich mich wie immer über fotos auf
instagram mit dem hashtag kies kitchen
ich wünsche euch einen guten appetit
danke euch für das einschalten und sagt
bis zum nächsten mal auf dieses kitchen
[Musik]